[Music]
the Obama administration they're spying
scandal continues to grow now yesterday
cheryl atkinson wrote an op-ed in the
hill was entitled it looks like obama
did spy on trump just as he apparently
did me now as we told you earlier in the
program sources telling Fox News the
former UN Ambassador Samantha power was
unmasking Americans almost one a day
joining us now with the reaction is the
author of the smear the host of full
measure cheryl atkinson and from the
american center for law and justice and
president Trump's attorney Jay Sekulow
Cheryl I just want to hand it to you
because you're right it did happen this
unmasking at a level we never even
imagined before I want people to hear
your story because this is so important
well mine began before we heard about
what the government had done to
Associated Press and Fox News before
Edward Snowden I had Intel sources come
to me and suggest that I was likely
being monitored by the Intel community
or by certain actors and the Obama
administration because of the stories I
was doing long story short some people
in the Intel community helped me because
they thought this was so egregious had
forensics done on my computers multiple
computers from CBS and my personal
computers and three independent exams
have seen and proven forensics that they
used government proprietary software to
monitor my keystrokes planted
confidential classified documents in my
computer watch much about well what I
was doing exfiltrated files listened in
on my audio we have dates times and
methods for a lot of this as well as
government-owned IP addresses found in
my computer Jay Circulo this is not the
country that I know with Fourth
Amendment protections against
unreasonable search and seizure you know
though that that sounds to me like the
weaponizing of the tools of intelligence
to attack people they don't like or
political opponents well we know that
was in fact what happened so let's be
clear about a couple things that would
our friend James Rosen what happened
Cheryl would happen to others the idea
that you would utilize the intelligence
community to spy on your enemies
domestically which a
and it is not only outrageous but it's
illegal couple that with the fact and we
now know this the unmasking that was
going on and by the way the UN
Ambassador Samantha power is unmasking
basically almost a person a day and it
specially picked up towards the end of
the their political run if you will at
the end of their term President Obama's
term ask yourself this question why did
they decide at that point to quickly
start unmasking and that means by the
way we're talking about American
citizens as well that are being unmasked
by the UN Ambassador and she served
within the National Security Council
well that's great but the fact is this
unmasking which was supposed to have not
take place too often we're supposed to
utilize minimum or minimization
techniques apparently these were
advisory rules for the previous
administration rather than the actual
rules and laws that apply and I think
the the tragedy in all of this is the
American people are the ones that pay
the consequence
so if Samantha power Susan Rice Ben Rose
and again in the case of Samantha power
I'm asking a person a day when is that
when did that become the role of the UN
ambassador that's beyond bizarre and
that's unprecedented and that raises
questions this was all political but
here's my question with all the the
non-stop chatter in the media about
Russia Russia Russia Russia it's clear
they've now got a big target on Paul
Manafort for example but then you've got
all those people on masking surveillance
intelligence leaking a crime you got all
the Hillary Clinton's felonies we've
been over there's many many times then
you got a leak a day then you got Muller
and and Rosenstein and call me where is
the Congress where is the Special
Counsel what is the Attorney General
doing here and doesn't it should they be
playing a big role in investigating what
seems to be real crimes and maybe
constitutional violations like in the
case of Cheryl well look I think that
first of all we they may be doing that I
mean with Sean I mean if it was done
properly if there's an investigation
going on we would not know that so I
would I would hope that the whole aspect
of the leaking scandal that is taking
place
now for months and months and months
including conversations that the
President had with foreign leaders I
mean this is not something that should
be tolerated in any administration no
matter what your political leaning is I
mean this is just the out and frankly
illegal again an outrageous but we know
that it was taking place
so what we're hopeful is that there is
actually an investigation going on now
you don't know this for a fact
it's speculation on my part I don't have
any independent knowledge of it but you
necessarily would not so you know would
not necessarily know that there was so
you can be hopeful that there is in fact
an ongoing investigation and that this
you know aspect of leaking national
security matters will stop Cheryl I I've
had good people in the intelligence
community that told me I was unmasked
I've never been able to corroborate that
I have no idea if that's ever happened
I'm watching what happened to you and
you can give dates and times what
recourse as a citizen with
constitutional rights you have because
you can prove your case not much I mean
the only reason I can prove it is
because I had helped from people inside
the Obama Intel community that thought
this was so egregious they gave me the
tools that I wouldn't normally have had
to find this information forensically I
have a two-and-a-half-year-old lawsuit
there's a hearing tomorrow in fact
against the Department of Justice which
the current Department of Justice
continues to fight rather than directing
them to tell the truth follow the law
and get at the facts they're continuing
to fight this in federal court that's
the only recourse that most people can't
do that it's very expensive and
time-consuming it's very hard to sue the
government you have to go through a lot
of processes get permission it's it's
almost insurmountable all right we will
continue our investigation they